this is the last scene cinematographer
helena hutchins ever filmed alec baldwin
rehearsing a shooting scene moments
later the gun was fired killing her and
injuring the film's director
new mexico police have released all the
files associated with the ongoing
criminal investigation into miss
hutchins death
officers can be seen arriving on the
scene of a film set transplanted into a
real life tragedy
inside the church where the shooting
happened investigators attempt to piece
together the moment hollywood superstar
baldwin shot dead hutchins the last i
got from her was it went in through her
right and out the left back outside
officers inspect baldwin's clothing he's
still dressed as the cowboy character he
was depicting in the film he pulls us
briefly to answer his mobile phone
baldwin has denied pulling the trigger
on the gun which killed hutchins and
says he doesn't know how live rounds
came to be on the set
okay what is your phone
the film's armorer hannah gutierrez reid
is also captured on police body cam in
the immediate aftermath of the shooting
the 24 year old was responsible for
safety of guns on the set she is now
suing the weapons provider alleging he
supplied a mismarked box of ammunition
containing live rounds
a report by the state of new mexico last
week found the producers of the film
were responsible for the death of helena
hutchins saying they showed a plain
indifference to employee safety
there could yet be criminal charges
brought the entirety of that police
investigation into the shooting which
horrified hollywood is now in the public
domain martha kellner sky news